hello and welcome to uh Los Santos
really beautiful hd Los Santos on this
very special episode of Gamespot now
playing we are now playing Grand Theft
Auto 5 Next Generation look at this next
generation of Windows phones Happening
Here uh this is on the PlayStation 4 I'm
playing this video game on and uh if
you've watched gam spot live streams in
the past you'll not I'm a big fan of GTA
uh when the game first came out on Xbox
360 I played it for 12 hours and though
we're not going to play for 12 hours
here uh we're going to play the entire
time let's say I don't know an hour and
a half maybe uh in first person mode
because that is the sort of new part
from the uh uised visuals the sort of
new lighting models the longer jaw
distance and all of the fancy uh uh
upgrades that it's been given H the
biggest one is this first person view
mode uh which can be done in when you're
just walking around when when you're
shooting when you're in a car any
vehicle apparently some parts are easier
than others uh I edited the video review
for Mark Walton which is up on the side
at the moment we gave it a nine out of
10 but I have never played this up until
this point checking my phone here is the
only thing I've done in first person and
I got to say it's already awesome look
at this look at this [__] yo Molly
what's up what's going on what else we
got here can I do first person selfies
now oh no that was always the
same hey what's going on
hey all
right enough about that let's go for a
dip uh so the thing about first person
is you can when you start by default
it's using just the normal like GTA 5
third person camera which means like you
tap X to run and stuff like that so if
you go into the controls you can set it
so you know left uh analog stick is run
and stuff like that so uh there's a
bunch of different controls for the per
first person stuff I want to do an
what's my jump button Square I guess cuz
it's first person
shooter Circle no that's punch dudes
X's all right let's just jump
it ooh first person swimming this isn't
deep
enough there you
go first person getting out of the pool
first person oh let's go in the
house so that one of the funny things
about this is the like stuff that was
some that looks really good like this
looks pretty good but then there's like
some stuff that you clearly were never
supposed to see in first person like
this sick plant for
instance uh others include the rear car
doors or rear car seats uh and the rear
view mirror as well actually I guess
slow he walks if you don't
run is this like default house
speed I will be keeping my eye on the
chat as well on
gamespot.com um so if you have any
suggestion please let me know but for
the moment uh going to do a couple of
missions this is one of Mark's earlier
saves in the game so he's got a bunch of
stuff not unlocked so I'm going to do
that and then just do the usual sort of
GTA exploring look at that rear view
mirror oh it's like I'm
wasted whoa sorry H one of the things
Mark mentioned in his review is that the
driving was really difficult because of
how Twitchy it is so I'm just going to
try and drive as fast as possible and
see how I see how I do that hey you
don't have to do this in in first person
obviously you can just knock it back to
third person and for instance if you
like get out of the car and you're like
oh I'm in first person here but you go
back in it'll remember what you used
before what your default is so that
works for if I'm outside as well just
wandering around I'm like I want to be
in third person when I'm outside and you
hop back
in bam I like I said earlier the
settings because when Mark was initially
playing he's like for first few minutes
he was like that running stuff is really
annoying but there are so there's a
bunch of different like um sort of uh
customization options here like kind of
crazy stuff like the sensitivity when
you're walking around when you're
aiming uh the different versions of like
the first person um controls you can
have when you're walking around the
sensitivity when you're on foot when
you're in the car you can have it so
that it doesn't or does ragd doll when
you combat roll or when you rag doll um
so yeah there's there's a bunch of stuff
here uh it's pretty good they've kind of
I don't know seem to think of quite a
lot of uh permutations that people might
have but one of the most exciting things
is just how I don't know like bigger the
city feels when you're playing in first
person especially when you're on foot
when you're like shooting people and
stuff uh bump up the feel of view give
it a go someone in the chat cash 222 is
asking to do that I'm Daniel wi in the
gam spot chat so if you have any
questions please send
them
here Okie doie what else we got field of
vision we should set it to a nice
um on foot set it to a nice uh 120 Quake
3 shall
we on foot fov is only there is there
like a here okay let's get out and have
a look
so this is
my field
division normally so the car is taking
up let's say
80% of my fov
there this is for when I'm using my rail
gun all right there's not really that
much of a difference it's kind of gotten
a little bit wider I think I like this
more actually I think I like this bit
more so does it translate when you're in
the car I can't really
tell uh all right let's go for a
wander go for a wander in the the
streets of Los Santos maybe down VPI
Pier how about that let's go down vuchi
pier and maybe murder some people oh
maybe should steal an airplane maybe
steal an airplane cuz then we can see
how good the first person stuff it looks
like in an airplane also then we can
jump out of an airplane there's too many
things to do in this video
game okay we're going to go to
ammunation I'm going to make sure I've
got a parachute then we're going to go
to the airport steal a plane where's
nearest
ammunation
sure uh steel
plane I wonder if knocking people down
in first person is way more traumatic
let's try that out hey lady come back
here
oh god oh
no oh that's
terrible get out of the way get out of
the way get out of the way get out of
the way
[__] okay okay well if this wasn't a
murder simulator before uh yeah eat it
whoa that dude on the bike's going to
eat it next get out of the
way can I do I have a gun yet oh I do
can I can I first person can I drive by
people God how do I even do this
anymore so L want to bring it up or one
to shoot Jesus this is this is
crazy just in I so I'm holding L1 to
bring my gun up and then holding or one
to shoot while also holding both
triggers for
driving yeah this is
difficult need
it all right amination might have to
wait look at this guy oh bike bike bike
bike bike bike bike give me the bike
give me the bike give me the bike damn
it things used to be so easy in normal
GTA are now incredibly difficult in this
first person mode but I kind it's kind
of
cool I like it it's kind of
like kind of like expert level or
something I might try and complete the
entire game like
this it's like crazy how different this
makes the world feel considering all it
is is a l camera change there's another
bike there's another bike all right
watch this I'm going to steal this bike
as hard as driving is I bet driving on a
bike is way harder it look it's so nasty
it's so nasty knocking people over in
this look at this guy hey what's going
on
h
ah this is what regular people this is
the way they feel when they see PE when
they see GTA played in third person like
the sort of the nasty real violence of
it I can now empathize with how they
feel all right all right let's get away
from the cops and do a sick wheelie do a
sick wheelie bro
no
Jesus
jeez this is great oh
[__] oh my God oh my God I want this typ
Oculus rip support so bad look at this
[__]
yeah sick sick break here at the
end [__] wrong
button what's what's what's E
bra oh I can shoot when I'm on this that
seems like it's really easy and a good
idea do the old right trigger left
trigger nonsense
again whoa [__]
whoa [__] get out of here get out of
here is there water under here that's
not water oh dead
all right that was pretty
cool I'm into this
already if you're just joining us uh
welcome we're playing Grand offt Auto 5
on the Sony PlayStation video game
console
4 uh and that's a lot of fun uh that car
crash was
hilarious I'm really into this okay okay
got sidetracked a bit there it's going
to happen it's going to happen a
lot oh okay Vanilla Unicorn is right
there
but all right taking votes Vanilla
Unicorn or ammunation I'm going to start
walking down the street you
guys you guys figure that one out I
don't want to drag us to a strip club if
you don't want to
go hey what's going on hey what's going
on how you doing hi is this weird is
this weird is this
weird you want to dance you want to
dance let's do it let's do it come on oh
you [__] H I've knocked your glasses off
stupid
jerk yeah you want
some beat you up too in your sick plaid
shirt yeah beat you up you just ran
through your Budd that was weird all
right where's the last one I just throw
this grenade at you come on you want it
you want some
[__] oh God oh
God oh God that's really awful all right
I'm out of here I'm out of here you know
what this reminds me of it reminds me of
postal postal
2 skydiving people want to see skydiving
all
right get out of here I love the field
of vision stuff that happens there when
you're wiring the car it is so Twitchy
driving it's not the ideal way of
playing this but I kind of like it cuz
it reminds me of what I'd be like if I
was trying to drive
uh a getaway car
whoa okay the police laugh to me they
are damn it I better hide servicing
sounds
good let's just hide down here for a
moment shall
we let's check my
messages uh turn off
come on police go away go
away come again another
day are they coming in the alleyway God
damn
it is a standoff
happening eat
grenade [__] I keep dropping him like
that
[__] all
right
that's oh that's gruesome that is
gruesome who's next you want some who's
next oh God damn
it it's weird I guess I was playing it
like a first person shooter but then
forgetting that this is GTA and you do
not have the Health allowance you have
when you're in a normal first person
shooter
um all
right okay okay okay this time I'm not
going to get in trouble from the police
swear to God
I won't pull a Grenade on a bunch of
bunch of
dudes I wonder if I already have a
parachute I don't
okay okay we get to enjoy first person
car theft in the rain this
time hey lady what's going on you want
to feel the end of this bumper sure you
do get
out oh okay
God this looks great this rain looks so
much better on this
console just the lighting the lighting
like across the board is so much better
look at that
rain look at them bubbles them
bubbles whoa all
right let's go pick up
a hey what's going on
buddy H I
want is the thing are these is it an
armor no is there people shooting
outside oh no
that's
tops
no
AAL here we are oh he hasn't unlocked
him
yet oh well you know what the second
best thing
from uh parachuting is just jumping out
of a plane without a parachute yeah sure
auto save why
not okay let's try and break into the uh
into the airport get your ass over
there okay
aeroporto so we want to get
down
here
ASAP uh yeah we can swap to characters
as well but I have a feeling the first
person flying is probably what people
want to see especially in a jet I want
to see what it's like in the jet I've
not seen that yet I've seen screenshots
and video of the crop dusters and stuff
but not inside of the Jets yet whoa oh
yeah oh I've banked
myself I don't even know how I pull that
off that's amazing all right which one
of you jerks wants to give me your car
yeah you're a nice car give me that
one what's first person car jocking like
yeah get
out God that's surprisingly easy I might
have to try that in real
life
no song
sucks n
Santos all right I'm really into this
God the lightning is
great we're not that far from the
airport
anyway uh I'm hoping there's no problem
stealing cars I know there's weird
unlock stuff that happens like with
the there's certain parts of the not
parts of the map but there's certain
buildings that don't kind of unlock
until later um I'm hoping that there's
not a situation where none of the planes
down here are actually stealable all
right let's let's rrap out of here yep
sure all right this is my favorite way
into the airport it's probably yours too
it's so crazy how more sensitive the
driving
is look at that rain oh looks so good
all right it's my favorite way into the
airport oh didn't get enough speed but
whatever
first person rag down might be my
favorite part of this video game uh okay
I've not uh I've not actually flown in
first person yet so there's a very good
chance that I might just crash so I hope
not I hope not there's no [__]
Choppers there's no Choppers straight
away there's no Choppers that's the
problem but there's a lar Jet right
there so
hopefully hopefully this one will
we'll work before the popo get
here oh please work please work please
work please work yes hit it
yes okay I'm just going to take this oh
this is so cool uh okay I'm going to
swap to third person for a second
because I want to make sure I don't hit
anything which is usually the the first
thing that happens when you do this
so all right controls the same way no
view from the air
okay back to first
person at that helicopter oh don't hit
that thing don't hit that thing [__] why
I broke the windshield that's really
going to make flying difficult all right
to
Infinity I can't believe the
windshield's
broken up we go and then I'm going to
click in to make the air to make the
landing gear come
up
no is there a different button for it
this
time it says gear
down must be a different button I don't
know what the button is so I'm just
going to do
that no oh it's that one sorry wrong
one sweet this is first
person
flying in this
in this pressureless cabin I'm in now
all right let's uh let's mix it
up
[Music]
whoa all right it's pretty cool let's go
higher okay so usually when I do look
backwards in the cars and stuff it just
does it in um it does it in first person
but obviously just I can't see anything
if I look back in this
so I don't care about my air
speed all right this is pretty
cool remember years ago people used to
say why don't they do first person GTA
like why don't they I hope the next
whenever the next GTA comes out I hope
it's in first person and I kind of never
really got
it
but
this is really cool this really changes
your perspective on uh you know no pun
intended on
um on the scale of the
city there's something a better as well
it's not it's just it's not that it's
more difficult to to control but you
just feel like you're closer to the m
the Machinery that when you're in it so
when you're in the car you just
notice the sort of subtle left and
rights way more than you would
and it's the same in this plane like the
turbulence usually in GTA never bothers
me when I'm sitting out here it's like
yeah whatever it's oh [__] turn turn
turn turn turn um it never really
bothers me but in this for some reason
it's every time the the plane like
jutters a little bit it just feels super
sensitive all
right I
should jump out I could try and land it
actually you know what I'll try and land
it first
h no let's just jump it it be more
fun where are we over
Chiliad
okay as high as this thing wants to get
at the
moment oh it's so crazy not being able
to see so the camera swaps back
automatically as well when you look not
sure if you can switch
that uh let's go back towards the city
just slightly we can see if we land on
something all
right let's get out of here three 2
[Music]
[Laughter]
one oh just this is terrible
F oh this is
terrifying like no concept for how high
I was that was
[Laughter]
awful oh that's
great oh I love that it showed him like
getting out of the cockpit and then
jumping out they must have had to done a
bit of work to like ensure that that
stuff was animated but that uh that like
the the animation downtime wasn't wasn't
like elongated for whatever reason
because usually when you hit like you
know I want to get out of the car now
you hit the button so gameplay wise you
want to get out of the car at that
moment but then they have to they
somehow have to like animate it within
that time frame they must have extended
them slightly or something all right
we're in uh Sandy Shores here uh let's
try out somebody else got a good friend
Trevor let's see what he was
doing oh Bo he's up near he's up near
the army
base is
he oh was going to show him do something
nasty in first
person great
beard oh that is that is just
nasty is there oh God for some reason
this is like like way worse n in first
person
ooh a Brit of all right I like
it got some blood on the
wall it's that guy that I think I might
be doing stuff
with sticky
ribs caution hot pizza I don't even know
what that is looks like wiping my butt
on the floor drink whiskey
yeah everything's in first person
now water still looks like crap but
whatever
liquid uh more whiskey I want to get rip
[__] in first person see what that's
like yeah it's really weird this is
reminding me of like this is like the
worst comparison to make ever but this
is reminding me of postal 2 a lot in
just the egregious amounts
of public violence and like dumb stuff
that's in first person and now drinking
which was also a thing in that all right
I think we're pretty drunk let's stop
drinking cuz at a certain point when you
keep drinking it actually it actually
makes you less drunk all right whoa all
right I'm not moving the camera
here hey what's going on what's going on
who [__] on the
floor who knocked over on my
plant let's go outside
I'm going to take the
shortcut all
right let's go cause some
Havoc look at these guys just chilling
out just chilling out like a bunch of
dudes well how about you have this how
about
that I forgot how to explode it damn it
damn
it oh there you go oh who okay did you
survive nope this is so much darker look
at this
[__] somebody's going to put this on on
Fox today you know that
bam why did you all run
away it's trying to get used to the like
used to playing GTA but then using other
controls like whoa nope
like where the hell is zoom oh this
one's running right towards me let's get
a bit personal
then this is so
dark this is so dark hey what's going
on shoot you in the leg
yep is this weird Echo thing happening
cuz I guess I'm
drunk this is so
dark oh video games are the worst thing
in the world Jus Christ you [__]
kid it's okay I got this present for you
there you
go it's yours don't open up before
Christmas it's
this oh no this whole like weird Echo
thing that's happening cuz he's drunk
makes it seem like this is he's having
like some sort of mental
breakdown oh I've got no grenades God
damn it hey what's up cop how do I
zoom I'm too I'm too
wasted
this how do I is thr a cover button over
is that it oh yeah okay I think this is
it yeah got a cover button
[Applause]
here you suck
[__] no that way that side that
side oh they're
everywhere there's a good amount of
uh uh pop on that uh Zoom or Auto auto
zoom on
that but I think that was probably a
stupid place to try and take cover so if
I H L1 I'll take cover behind anything I
guess oh there's a cop car cop car cop
car wait there's cops in it damn it D
it all right get in the car get in the
car get in the car get in the car go to
sleep [__] go to sleep get in
the car get in the
car yeah this is definitely more
challenging in first person and kind of
more awful which means also more awesome
so let's get out of here get out of away
I'm a
policeman [__] [__] yep you're
definitely dead
I need
a
die wait why do my bullets not break the
windshield I have Magic
Bullets oh I wonder if I haven't tied my
seat belt
oh die oh I definitely killed that guy
already that's
great die this is great this is
BR can I see I can't see anything [__]
SW get out of my civilians it's not your
fault I'm
sorry all right can I shoot
backwards
no God damn it all right where's where's
the getaway plan here
[__] I could maybe dve try and drive off
this poci
pier I could just keep going oh there's
definitely a tire R and I don't know
which one it
is God damn it
oh yeah I don't know what Tire's gone
but something's
gone okay I'm going to try and drive off
this VCI pier and
hide these [__] don't kill
me it's like really hard to usually in
this situation you'd know if there was
like a SWAT car behind you or something
but it's just it's between this
absolutely ridiculously useless
windshield mirror and the fact that I
can't turn around without like
everything's in the way it's like
totally changed it where's the Pier
where's the Pier next one next one next
one turn turn turn stup
car okay run the road to Freedom
everyone get out of the way everyone I'm
a criminal and I will murder you get out
of the way get out of the [__] way
get out of the way I told you get out
[Laughter]
way see if
[__] oh this is the
best all right swim underwater before
they see you how do I swim
underwater let's do
that great Where's My Car
gone somebody shooting me
already I got to go underneath this uh
under take this
pier whereas Shawn mcginness would say
there's probably a bunch of HD dudes
banging each
other where am I where's the where's the
this
way swimming looks like Far Cry yeah
that's not a bad [__]
actually um I don't want to do that
specific Mission um cash 22 because just
in case spoilers there's a little clip
of it in the video review but I don't
want to get um try that uh mini gamees
actually yeah yoga or golf in first
person that's a good that's a good shout
actually let me um let me go to the golf
course and see if uh I'm able the golf
is in first person cuz that' be crazy
that means they' have to have
like surely like have to have
redeveloped a bunch of those mini games
cuz the roller coaster was already in
first
person I think most of the stuff in the
fairground was look at that light Bloom
that's
amazing it's all dark here you can see
it like popping through there at high
dynamic range yeah it's great this game
looks
great these forward rolls are the
dumbest thing I've ever
seen oh [__] I forgot I've got
that slow motion murder I forgot about
using that like nonstop during the
during the main game oh they SL can't
find me they SL can't find
me am I free I'm free we shocked them
hooray
great let's see if there's any uh
activities up
here remember all those people I
murdered up here a few minutes ago that
was
fun
hey hey what's going
on I don't want to make a b de hey
what's up
okay why are people shouting at
me hey are you going to sell me
something can I have this burger this
awful rotten Burger normal Burger double
Burger Kings size mea cheese bacon
burger can I eat your coffee can I have
your
coffee someone's on the no all
right oh this guy this guy will s me
something hey what's going
on
[__] go and [__] yourself I'm going
to [__] kill you come on now make me
suffer
douchebag come on let's dance let's
dance all right let's play rock paper
scissors rock
paper scissors [__] scissors
that's
crazy this is so nasty this is like the
worst look at this look how awful this
is now look
how oh God oh God I can't stop either
I'm like yeah I'm gonna go to the golf
course and see if that's in first person
but no I just end up murdering people
again they seem to run away faster maybe
it's just because in first person
everything like looks so much closer cuz
look at oh I had no idea I was topless
and bleeding that badly is that my
blood I had no idea imagine if a guy
started going around murdering people
and you were stuck in like a ferris
wheel and like every time you came down
it was like oh he's going to get
me oh well our friends the police going
to turn up again I wonder if the jet
skis are down there actually let me
check any jet skis any jet skis down
here let's jump off this and see if oh
[__]
ow that
hurt uh yeah there's some jet skis
there's some jet idiots riding them come
here come here before the police come I
need you I need to comeand Deer your ve
vehicle this is a good time to figure
out how this Zoom
works it's not any of either of the
triggers it's not
no click in no it's not triangle it's
not forward
roll I don't know I am at a loss unless
it's like click in the touchpad nope all
right well that jet ski is also just
disappeared so unless it comes back I'm
going to have to get a car and push one
of these ones in hey what's going on I
have a gift for you enjoy
it you don't want it you don't want it
you don't want it too
late lifeguard help this
man oh oh God all
right let's
go can't knock these ones
in all right no jet SK for Dy oh well
let's get out of
here uh try oh [__] I was not looking at
my computer screen and now this is
happening think fast think fast think
fast you round think fast
copper it's so nasty this is the
nastiest thing in the world look at the
I love the fact that there two cups of
coffee there for the
cops H okay no not third
person okay taking suggestions
again golf has changed a lot since you
last played that's true um maybe I
should try and lose these cops but I've
got three stars so maybe not maybe let's
go and one more murderous Rampage and
then I'll try
golf so I'll try and get killed near the
golf course at
least but where should I do the
Rampage let's set up like a roadblock oh
here we
go
[__] I think I'm wedged between
yep no the car landed on me get
away
okay
um trying to get out of
here I'm an innocent man I know I'm
topless and covered in blood and
carrying a shotty but it was the other
guy I'm having way too much fun with
this I've literally completed this game
and played it for I don't know let's say
about 60 hours or so this is like
absolutely hilarious I'm just going to
I'm going to stay I'm going to stake out
an area here I'm going to cause like a
rampage Zone get those to come
here that'll do
it all right come at me dudes I'm going
to put this bit of C4 here we'll come
back to that later oh there fire there
don't want to get on
fire who wants
some I'm going to hide in this ancient
Chinese building
oh there's no there's no cover in this
whatsoever okay oh [__] uh where's the
cop where's the Poli where's the chopper
gone hey what's going on oh wow
Ice uh yes you can um you can choose
apparently um uh online first person
stuff you can do all of GTA GTA online
first person if you want but then when
you're actually doing the uh missions
and stuff you can like force first
person if you want as well which pretty
cool okay I'm sorry I keep getting into
murderous Rampages but uh in the future
if I do go on a real world murderous
rampage this is the footage you can
use to uh say it there were early
warning signs and none of you did
anything uh okay look at that car it's
so nice give me that
car give me your a nice car I want to be
in a convertible in first
person get out get out of my car it's my
car now get out get
out this isn't
convertible damn it it won't convert
don't text and
drive all these messages you got look at
that oh there's new guns in guns and
ammo
[__] I actually quite like the driving
now I think I've gotten a little used to
it it's I think if I was in a mission
this would be a lot more frustrating but
for pottering around it's uh it's all
right so now we're going to
see don't make me knock you down on the
way into my fancy Golf
Course uh now we're going to see if the
first person
stuff happens in uh in the golf course
too so where do I go to
play cool start
game
I love how explaining God to me oh my
God yes oh yes oh this is better than I
ever could have
imagined hey there we should
proposition uh which is hole number one
is it you you're three no it's par
three whole
one sure
is it number three part three can I just
go in any order I want I'm going to go
in any order I
want skip to T L1 all
right are we still in third person
a see if I can change the camera
nope that's a
shame let's do
that see if maybe if I get into it it'll
do it
no so it's standard I guess the only
difference is the car stuff the buggy
stuff is
uh I nearly went is in first
person so perhaps that's indicative of
all the other
uh modes as well I'm going to
quit yeah I want a quick
golfu all of you you suck Trevor
all right let's check in our boy
Franklin see where he's
at cycling in first person uh I believe
it is let me check the motorbike stuff
was and that was absolutely insane
so I can only imagine the case is also
true for
cycling oh look at his
Pad can I play with chop in first person
that's the real question look at
that this place so
fancy it's look how really running
here yeah he should have a motorbike
right this is this
guy oh yeah there's a
motor we could probably find a cyclist
up in uh up in the
Hills this is crazy you can look down
whoa
whoa see if we can just do like stupid
driving like in when you usually do in
GTA God the foliage and stuff is so much
more detailed I don't think I
noticed how detailed this stuff was
until I got
here uh okay let's uh let's go for a
nice
mountainous Excursion
uh let's go enter no let's go this
way there's always a chance of meeting a
cyclist up around
here oh [__]
oh the crashes are so
nasty get back on back in your bike
son
yeah I wonder if there's like other
missions now that are like way easier
and other ones that are way more
difficult because of the first person
like I can imagine uh according to the
review Mark said that for instance the
one where you're trying to get Michael's
son from the Bose where he's hanging off
it's like a pretty early mission uh is
significantly harder in first person
person because you're trying to hit this
like I guess you just need spatial
awareness of your car which you do not
have when you're doing this like I'm
looking back there it's
like even that little animation
delay might totally change how you play
like I bet this is crazy in first person
in in GTA Online in first
person all right cyclist watch
[Music]
whoa
is that a
cyclist nope wrong way wrong
way let's go Offroad a bit whoa this is
difficult whoa
[__] from that
relax
okay I'm going to launch this thing
Offroad in a
second see how crazy it gets see if it's
any way controllable when you stop being
a good
boy let's do
it
[__] oh [__] oh
[__]
a didn't even get a little ragd doll
there I wish the waste had came
up yeah I tried to do wheelie in first
person earlier it's uh it's pretty
cool forward on the right stick is zoom
with sniper rifle it wasn't when I was
doing it in first
person
um is
problematic like I said earlier the
controls have like been set to first
person mode because it the normal GTA
controls are kind
of all over the place like tapping X to
run if you're playing a first person
shooter would seem like absolute Madness
H all right you know what actually you
know what we haven't done is done a
mission so let's just try and do that
let's go to Devon see if there's a
mission to
do yeah my
way let's actually play GTA the way it's
meant to be played the reflections are
AR look at that look look at that
reflection that Wing mirror and the one
in the middle as well is pretty terrible
like basically unusable cosmetic get out
of the
way it's so difficult not to try and
just murder
everyone that's the other thing is I
keep forgetting who I
am it's like I guess you can tell by
their hands but like how often do you
look at someone's hands in a first
person shooter like I keep forgetting
which character I am like Franklin
talked there when he robbed that car I
was like oh yeah I'm Franklin forgot
about that so that's kind of weird so I
guess that like whole first person thing
about you being the character like there
is no Gordon Freeman kind of speaks
volumes here
hello hey what's going on guys oh you
must be Michael's boy oh man some all
right I'm skipping
this get in the
car let's try and do an actual mission
in
GTA in first
person oh I like this car a
[Applause]
lot I can't remember this Mission get to
the gas station am I stealing cars for
him at this
stage uh nope this
way me in GTA 4 they had the they used
to have the indication lights indicators
would blink when you're you're supposed
to go left and
right and they took that out I don't
know why they took that out must been
confusing people this is cool driving on
freeways is so much cooler in this mode
I'm going to knock this guy over
ah where'd he go there he
is oh I took a wrong
[Music]
turn oh you think you got away you think
you got oh
sh hey look out fools my
whoa this is way scarier that way all
right sorry guys I missed my
turn
Okay woo I think I'm getting used to the
driving the aiming stuff is absolutely
crazy this is just I don't know how
you're supposed to figure this this is
like this is some tapping your head and
rubbing your stomach
nonsense uh one of the other um new
additions in this version of GTA is
there's a lot more traffic I guess with
the increased processing power uh
especially on the freeways there's a lot
more
uh
death H there's a lot more there's a lot
more uh traffic around so I'm wondering
as well is that are there certain
missions that are more difficult or or
easier based on that cuz traffic
sometimes can help to like get cops head
it away you drive down the wrong side of
the freeway while there's a bunch of
traffic it can be a lot
easier
um all right here's the gas
station think we're sealing a car I do
not
know oh it's a street race okay so this
should be interesting [__] this7 see
which one of you two is for Real your
cars and let's see if they move as fast
as your
mou you want me to get a hooker I've
seen what happens in first person when
you get a prostitute in this game
already cuz I asked Mark to do it for
the video review which I subsequently
did not put it in the video review
but it's in first
person so that bit where you grab the
back of the lady's head is in first
person so I don't really want to do that
here if you don't
mind maybe the end maybe at the end
[__] oh this is this is not easy wow
okay yeah so I remember this level
actually being difficult oh you [__] I
remember
this uh being difficult
in the game in third person
so it might be too difficult
here once I get up into traffic I can
start using Franklin's crazy driving
skills thing but I don't want to do it
right here see this traffic might be
helping this is way more traffic than
you usually get in GTA come on come on
get that grip on that
t okay here we go here we go here we go
start overtaking these
noobs I don't like this race cuz I don't
know where I'm supposed to go
just straight down the
road squeeze in between you
guys out me
way
[__] who [__]
hold it hold it hold it hold it pull it
back pull it back oh
[__] get out of Zoom
[Music]
mode it's going to ask me to repeat it
isn't it
ah this is one of the levels I hated in
the first
game those guys have disappeared off my
radar come
on catch up catch
up I don't use any more that slow-mo
sauce while I'm
here all right I got one of
them here's number two ahead of
me oh I do
it yeah hey coming up now man be there
in a few seconds got
it whatever here they come all right
more first
person this is cool this is
cool I turn on my siren they're too far
ahead we got to catch up to them if we
want to
stop this one's on the side of the road
oh my God this is cool oh my God this is
cool it's so hard to control this thing
all
right this visor thing in night time is
a nightmare it just makes everything
black whoa oh I can't see which lights
are the closest ones I'm just going to
stay out here
okay Jesus Christ this is so much harder
in first
person I'm just going to stay oh I
barely hit missed that road see like if
I wipe here like that's
it like that's pretty much Mission over
right I guess you could like Swap this
to third person but like what's the fun
in that we got to stick with them they
got to stop
sometime
oh man I'm glad we got like a driving
heavy mission for this
because cuz this really shows off the
massive
like like the transformative ability of
first person if we can get a bit of
shooting in after this as well that
would be cool but this is cool like this
is this is totally different oh [__]
this makes the this makes this whole
mission feel completely
different
oh
manre they like I'm even just so it's
just it makes
everything in the immediacy like
everything that's close so much more
significant even like the lights on the
back of his car are something I never
would have noticed before that he barely
missed that
deer like never would have noticed
before but now it's
like it's like in my periphery it's what
I'm looking at to make sure that I'm
still on
track so from right we should St stop
him up on this
bridge that's up here the long one down
looks like our shot good my ass is dead
oh my God this
is oh please stop please stop before I
crash pull out my
gun yeah it's on this bridge they stop I
think come
on
yes sorry
Michael whoa hey stay in the car there
homeboy I'll deal with you later [__]
you
too you know how fast you were going see
I don't know officer I uh try to keep it
under the limit well you and your boys
look like you were drag racing from
where we are sitting there so uh why
don't you get yourself up out of the car
come on all right I'm going skip this
hey man you know how it was to drive
slow enough to I think all we do now is
bring these cars
back oh you talk oh yeah I need to have
a race with him now don't I scratch cars
without scratching the cars that's a
hell of a lot easier said than done
especially in first
person all right let's try out yeah sure
that's right yeah how to make this even
more dangerous ah the lady from before
Devon's assistant good to be working
with you it's Molly Schultz senior
president and general counsil to Mr
Weston's holding company and if you
think it's good to be working with
common thieves well you're very mistaken
have you got the cars wow the whole
resume yeah we got the cars bring them
to HA Auto on little BN these handle a
lot better than the bikes
anyway hey just spoke to devans manwoman
lawyer person I'll be waiting at ha with
South LS for you idiots to show up yeah
right come
on keep it on the
road
[__] sorry
truck this is a lot of fun I like this
like I don't I don't think the the
driving is
too like it's definitely way harder but
it's kind of nice bro these cars it's
like when you've been playing [__] oh I
[__] this car up pretty
fast
whoops oh why doesn't he look back there
weird sorry Mr Devon for totally ruining
the front of this car for you um it's
kind of like when you go when you're
playing like I guess it's kind of like
when you're if you ever played Drive
Club and then you went back and played
Forza it's like yeah forts is harder but
it's also like kind of more interesting
okay bad bad example because it's a lot
more interesting than godamn drive
Club it also works Drive Club doesn't
work always Burns Out The
End come on oh [__] oh [__] oh [__] oh
[__] hey
look all right you know what actually
it's going to take forever to complete
this Mission let's just quit
it
uh like anyone you oh no I'm right there
actually let just
do so yeah we've got a little bit left
on the Stream So if you have any
suggestion for what we should do stick
them in the Gamespot chat at Dan DWI if
possible be easier for me to see
[Music]
it yeah a bit of flying a bit I think I
think I kind of want to do bit more
shooting like a shooting Mission would
be
goodful B more turning around on the
freeway it's always fun what do you mean
how am I going to beat your ass in this
race don't worry I'm taking care of that
I mean is it just a smell of green I'm
going to beat his ass in the race but
I'm also totally destroyed this car
which I'm sure deon's not going to be
too pleased about hey I'm just trying to
do what's best for Frank you know help
him make the best the CH yeah I'm kind
of getting used to this driving actually
I saw her first don't get too creepy all
right she's a professional woman who's
doing a job there you go look at that
see that [__] speeding through easy
peasy lemon squares not on my watch I'm
serious both of you back off
hery
andren all right I'll keep my eye out
for ladies of night as
well sorry the music we are near the
Vanilla Unicorn as well
[Music]
actually great sorry I totally trashed
your car jet fighter skydiving in the
mountains take the cable car up I could
try shark hunting God this going to be
fantastic one kid and two old creeps um
the shark hunting stuff I'd say is in
first person um I don't think it's been
on lock yet I know the um I'll try and
get a
bike the just kiss homie boom is there
that M Chiliad mystery thing like the
message written in the cable car could
probably try and find that you finish
the job you get the shut up Deon I don't
care I'm sorry I [__] up your car I'm
not
sorry all
right I'm going to do a little bit of
wandering a little bit of walking around
look at this
guy what's up I would not be walking
around in that dress in this
neighborhood lady I don't
know uhoh is that is that uh is that
lady of the
night I think it might
be
think hey what's going
on I need a
[Music]
car get Starry the night
is it's really weird walking around in
first person because you suddenly become
aware of like there's a lot of people
walking around this kind of grimy part
of town pretty
late all right give me that car oh [__]
God damn it get up wait am I not am I
Michael
now I am a Michael I thought I was
Franklin that whole
time get out of the car this is my soda
pop
now let's found some nice
music did enjoy
[Music]
get in the
car
oh hey what's
up let's go some place nobody can record
us sure let's do
that guess I can say goodbye to any
political career I might have
had somewhere quiet here's a car park
you don't get more quiet than
[Music]
that
what are you horny for
baby oh this is the worst I instantly
regret this decision oh she only does
$50
is Josh what do you think we should
do he wish You' slates you could just
stick up just in case $50
yeah it is it is Mark's money I would
like $50
please
oh no
God
on I swallow your
cck
video
games
2014 oh God that feels
[Laughter]
great oh
God was it oh I was that was
amazing that was that was you know how
to treat a girl yeah sure do want a
little something else
ah I feel like I can really talk to you
yeah thanks for Thanks for the
Memories
bye I'm so
[Music]
lonely H I'm sorry in GTA tradition
there's only one way this
ends I'm going to need that $50
back come on
whoa
$7 with the rest oh 73 I made a
profit I can hear the rest of the office
screaming on a time delay all right I
got to get out of here the cops are
coming the cops are
coming oh back stre boys are playing I
got to turn this up I got to turn this
this my This Is My Jam it's my
jam
heartache tell me
why I want it that way all right
roadblock that's the way to do
it let's get the right gun
out no
way
therey you go that's it come on cops
come at me
[Music]
Bros
what she overcharged
me
this is so much nastier in first
person wait did I drop did I cook that
or did I drop
one oh yeah that'll do
it oh oh
[__] [__] get
it is that dude running around on fire
fine [__] no no no I keep dropping them
I keep dropping
them
whoa he grenade oh [__] I keep doing
that I got to prime it first and then
throw it that
way
where's the chopper
at
you God damn
it you can look backwards when you're
running that's
great I Did It For
Love he
grenade
oh I ate
it all right
all right I think we got a little bit
more
time I think we I think the magnum opus
was probably that lovely lady though
but this is great this is great hey
turns out GTA 5 first person it's pretty
great hey what's going on what's going
on what's going on Ulta buddy what's
up how you doing
hey you really what you talking to me to
be interesting these Devils they can eat
a dick man you eat a dick uh uh on your
buddy
uhoh I'll kick you [__] oh God damn
it you know what you're one nasty
[__]
like this is just so nasty now I can't
stop doing it nine but it's
just I think getting
into like altercations with cops in GTA
3 was one of my favorite things in video
games ever and I think doing it in first
person is going to be like so much more
fun ah it looks great too it all looks
great
[Music]
can I run a grenade well you can
but around the
grenade
yeah e grenade
too grenades for
everyone grenades for
everyone oh [__]
that blur effect is so good H oh wow
that was a nasty blood
[Music]
Splat who's next
uh uh uh uh H all right I'm going to rob
him I'm going to steal a jet
again
die [__] shoot me back
all
right getting out of here oh yeah I've
whoa whoa whoa I've got a bunch of uh
tires out this
time [__] [__] [__] [__]
[__] get out of the
[Music]
way oh [__] I'm going to hit this guy uh
where I want to be I guess is down here
again oh no there's that helicopter pad
right here right where am I I'm just
here there's a helicopter pad is it here
I think it's here I think it's here
let's see if this see if we can get a
chopper I think it's down there damn
[Applause]
it damn it oh this car is
effed where are you
at oh [__] did I turn the wrong way
again get out of the
way how bad I just want to see how bad
this car is yeah okay it's got like no
wheels I was wondering like this car
handling in this first person is BS but
no I've got no tires all
right you stop your car
immediately whoa whoa slippy
slidey I wish this route had less turns
because my car has no grip but okay
sure oh I'm drifting I'm drift sorry
lady I was
drifting oh
[__] leave me alone leave me
alone almost there we're going to get
there and there's going to be no
Choppers
but I'm pretty happy about my my hot
driving skills right
now
uh I think it's down here is where the
ch are oh maybe it's not here actually
no I don't think it is here it's not
here damn it where is
it there is it
there GH all
[Music]
right oh God oh God yeah I'm just going
to go in
here all right I'm going to I don't need
Google Maps GTA maps I can
figure this one out on my own no I can't
no I
can't where do I go next this way this
way through this sweet
fence's up
boys no I won't be doing
that
I having so much fun I'm definitely
picking this
up I wonder yeah I'm kind of R
interested to play GTA online actually
cuz I'm wondering if oh Jesus Christ
that was a sick fre freaking kick flip I
just did there um I'm wondering if this
like really changes if the perspective
like dramatically
changes interactions like I kind of love
to play it a first person only GTA
online
oh God oh
God okay am I close to it now this car
has survived quite a long time where is
the fraking hel area it's right by the
freeway I know
that might be around here
somewhere I might as well just go to the
airport at this
stage
considering his car has like no wheels
it's it's driving remarkably well I'm
sorry
gentlemen oh that's the that bump was a
human
body let me alone I'll shoot you I'll
shoot you all okay I'm going this
way I'm going this
way
yeah do you know where the helt is I
forget where it is where is it again
it's
right oh there it is okay there thank
you rob Handlery GTA expert Rob Handlery
saving the day thanks
dude
okay hel pad hel pad oh man I hope this
chopp is there feel like I've done a
pretty decent job surviving at least
wouldn't have made it without
Rob come on come on that's
it that's
[Music]
it yeah it's it's it's like it's added
another dimension of challenge or
something it's really cool oh is it down
there we go is it down there I think it
might be down there we go turn turn turn
turn turn turn
turn ah there's no
helicopters n there's no
helicopters [__]
it's like when you go to that hey what's
up guys yeah sorry I brought you guys
down here I thought we would take a nice
helicopter trip together but it's not
happening it's not happening doesn't
matter let's go to the airport instead
let's go there instead
die oh man I shot that dude that was
pretty
good how is this car not on
fire oh my God yes get out of [__]
way go go
go airport airport
don't tell me I have to turn
around God damn
it oh don't get stuck underneath that
wasn't me beeping the
horn how messed up is this
car look at this thing look at this look
at this thing it's got no front I
couldn't even tell cuz his first person
mode is oh God no don't sandwich me
please stop your car immediately
how is this thing
still we don't have much further to go
baby it's just you and
me think of all the memories we had on
this road trip ever since I stole you
from that other
person that guy I think I
murdered oh did I missed the turnoff God
damn
it American freeways still confuse me
whoa okay sure I'm going this way
sure oh no this car is
[__] oh yeah this car is at this car
is done this car is done all right all
right how high is this fall oh [__]
that's too high oh God oh God somebody
give me a car God damn
it all
right one more
time I'm just going to go to the airport
report not going to get distracted by
any prostitutes or civilians I can
shoot or
anything I'm just going to go to the
airport I can bring a
cab I could call a cab and go to the
airport maybe that's I'll
do I'll set a
wayo using my handy map which I already
have
there call a cab how do I call the cab
again it's been a while check this
settings phone
contacts downtown cab
coat I need a cab as soon as you can no
problem I'll have one there in a couple
of minutes thanks bro all I have to do
now is not assault somebody in the time
it takes for the C to
arrive what are you looking
at what are you looking at you want to
say something hey buddy what's up
[__] pigs hang around my crib every
day and [__] who I'm
sorry why is he okay I'm not a police
officer I have to go out there and light
for God's
sake get in get in get in get in no no
steal it don't steal it
[__] I pressed the wrong triangle oh
whatever uh hey I tried I really tried
not to get into an altercation perfect
timing I got a customer for you right
now
no I don't want to do your stupid taxi
missions go
away that you should only be a block or
two away that's fine I don't want to
pick up your dude I'm going to go to the
airport and steal myself an a aeroplane
or maybe a helicopter hopefully there's
a chopper there so we did the L jet
earlier this time I'm I'm going to try
and get a
jet and then we can jump out of the Jet
and that will be a live
stream that seems like a good ending to
a live stream
the the hooking up with that lady of the
night might have been a good ending as
well but I just had too much blood lust
I had to keep
playing I like this
[Music]
music all
right I always go up top here I don't
know why cuz then you have to ramp down
maybe I just like ramping down too
much let's do
it sick recovery
bro
do it canel that something came
up hello sir you look like a
pilot all right I guess I don't need
it come on helicopters cross your
fingers folks oh no don't want to go to
flight school want to go over this wall
and do a sick tumble oh [__]
Jesus why is there never Choppers
here all
right can I drive you right now great
okay drive you to the jet I already went
to the one on the right I'm going to try
this one on the left if you're used to
playing GTA you know the these are kind
of uh no that's not going to work is it
cuz it's got the ramp let's try it some
of these work some of them
don't this one does not work bringing me
back
here hello
sir sorry
sir uh okay we could just hop into that
again but I'm going to try and get a
proper big
one it doesn't seem to be
any those ones are never usually
stealable
let's just do it now while there's not
that many cops
[Music]
around it's the fly us ones are usually
the ones you get but let's see what
happens
nope sorry I got this super fast car I
can run away
in you [__] off right
now all right oh God my wheels are gone
already
oh yeah both these wheels are
gone oh
God think a Wheels this big it wouldn't
need
air all right I'm going to get in the
[Music]
jet God damn it stop your vehicle you
[__] you stop your vehicle vehicle
how about that how about that how about
to get in this vehicle how about that
get in the vehicle get in the get in
yes
okay for the benefit oh [__] oh [__]
reverse
turnam get
this [__] don't hit
that oh it's so hard to do this in first
person if you hit this thing off
anything it blows up okay we good we're
good we're good it's just a smashed wind
windshield oh it's just a fully smashed
windshield up we go landing gear up and
we're
away
woo Lola
Santos
try and do
it oh
yeah sweet one of 50
Bridges oh has this thing been injured
oh it has one of the engines gone
sugar we should be okay for a little
while be some nice
aerobatics it's okay engine you're
fine yeah so I guess that's uh that's
GTA 5 on the PlayStation 4 this nextg
version obviously looks better lighting
is a lot
better H but this first person mode
really the risk of saying the most TR
phrase possible it is a little bit of a
game changer uh in terms of the the
shooting H the driving as well but I
feel like the shooting and just you're
like way you can
way you see the city around you I guess
is very is fundamentally different it
feels
bigger the sort of civilians feel more
real Everything feels a lot more
immediate which is pretty cool I like it
I'm going to play through Grand Theft
Auto 5 again but then it was my favorite
game of last year so that is probably
unsurprising uh both these engines are
having a little bit of trouble so I say
we take to the skies as high as we can
before
the inevitable
happens oh is it
dead not now oh one of the engines gone
one of the both engines are
gone come
on all right it's been nice to knowing
you stream thanks for hanging out here
on gamespot.com this has been our now
playing of GTA 5 and I'm going to jump
out this plane three two
one
ah see you next
[Music]
time